so I guess uh yeah sorry for the delay a
little bit uh I I couldn't find water
somehow
um
um anyway so but uh
um okay let's get started
um so last time we talked about
um concentration in the quality which
was uh for some preparations uh for what
we need today or maybe the last lecture
and today we are going to go back to the
uniform convergence so we call that uh
our goal was to
uh to the uniform convergence
and we have proved some results for
example we have proved that
um I guess we the first thing we had is
that we say the excess risk is funded by
this uniform convergence right so we
basically care about something like the
soup
of the differences
um
so guys we have shown that the excess
risk
thank you
I don't know why I'm
something wrong with my okay
assess risk this is funded by for
example uh something like IO
H star minus L has H star
Plus
minus L height H where H is capital H
and we have used this to
um
get a certain kind of uniform
convergence result for example we have
shown that for
find a hypothesis class
we've got LH hat minus
um
L of X star this is bounded by
guys we have shown this technically but
this can be turned into excess response
we've shown this is less than
um
sorry
this
is
done
square root long H roughly speaking Over
N if you ignore other log factors
um and you can take soup over each in
Capital H and also for
hypothesis class parametrized by
class with
P parameters
we also have got something like L Theta
hat minus L height or I think there's
something wrong with my
clothes let me take a quick
right here
so we can get IO silk later in capital
Theta L Theta minus L has Theta
this is bounded by some kind of O till
your Square p over it this is what we
did like two lectures ago
so and you can think of this you know I
guess we have discussed this briefly so
this content this quantity these are in
some sense
complexity measures
of the hypothesis
and this is generally the type of new
results that we're going to get right so
we're going to have something that
decreases as then goes to uh infinity
and also there's another constant
um which is uh there's another factor
which is the hypothesis class right so
so basically eventually you will say
that you know if n is bigger than the
hypothesis class then you can get a long
tubule error box
so the problem with these two bound is
the following so the limitation
so the limitation
I think you can talk about you know
different limitations from different
perspectives but I think the basic
limitation of the this p h parameter
Bond here is that it requires
tend to be much bigger than P so that
this bond is
um going uh is small so and this is not
necessarily feasible
um in many cases and also this is not
really
um what happens in reality right so in
reality like in many cases n is smaller
than p
is quite often
it's not always the case but you know
it's pretty often it's more often in
um in the modern situation where you
have a so-called over parametricizing
network but over part my choice I guess
I'll Define that more carefully
um in the later course in the later
lectures but basically in the modern
setting when you have a deep artwork
your image Knight has like a million
examples but uh your parameters could be
something like 10 minutes or maybe 100
million sometimes could be billions
so of course this is not necessarily
always the case where sometimes you
still have like a is bigger than P
depending on the situation but generally
people found that it's useful to make
your network your P very large so
definitely it's not the case that you
won't earn to be much much bigger than P
that's definitely not true
so uh and the reason in some sense why
this is not capturing what happens in
reality is that this is not precise
enough right so not precise enough
in the sense that your complexity
measure is in some sense two worst case
right your complex measure is measuring
the complexity of all possible
parameters with all possible models with
P parameters but you are not special
specializing enough to some special kind
of models among all the models with P
parameters for example you cannot
achieve your case you know especially in
the kind of more classical language you
cannot distinguish
a sparse parameter from a dense
parameter you cannot distinguish for
example you have a parameter class where
Theta has not one normal
versus some hypothesis cost where Theta
has some two normal
right so in either of these cases the
parameter P the P will be showing up in
your bound so um and but not necessarily
the B the the uh the control of the norm
of the parameters so so that's why we
are looking for
something that can be more precise that
can
um not that can uh not depend on P but
depend on some more
um accurate characterization of the
complexity
so so so today our next lecture
and next few lectures in some sense
so what we're going to say our goal is
to prove something like I'll
so the hatch minus L High to the hat is
less than something like some complexity
of theta
and over n
and but this complexity measure could be
more fun grained than just a single
number P
and this complex measure could possibly
also depend on diffusion so this
complexity
may depend even on a distribution
distribution P where p is the
distribution of your data so maybe for
some distribution P or complexity is you
know smaller for some other distribution
P the complexity is higher and we are
trying to capture the intrinsic kind of
like difficulty of the learning problem
but of course you know like you know
there is this is somewhat subjective
because you know first you know like
this depends on a little bit on what you
believe uh that is happening in real
life right so if you believe that
the real parameter is as far as then you
probably should have a complex measure
that captures the L1 Norm of the of the
of the parameters right if you believe
that the ground choose parameter is you
know
um have other properties then you
probably should use a different
complexity measure
um so
um so but this is the general goal and
also the Practical kind of like way of
thinking about this is that you can
think of the right hand side as a
is something that motivates your
regularization right so the the
Practical impact I guess maybe are the
practical implication is that you can
use this complexity
of theta as a regularization
because if you just optimize your model
where you're going to find some
parameter Theta especially if you don't
have enough data you may have much for
Global Minima among the search space
right so but uh if you know that certain
complexity measure will make the bond
better then you can actively find
models with small complexity so you can
use this complex measure on the right
hand side um like you add this
complexity measure multiplied by Lambda
to your chaining loss so you get the
regular slots
so that you are more likely to find the
small complexity one which generalizes
better
okay so
um
I guess that's the the basic idea and
um
so
what we're going to do is that
um so we're gonna today the first part
is we're going to talk about
a week ago right before we were talking
about the the
uniform convergence right so this is our
tool right you want to prove that LH
minus L height h
um it's small for all possible age
and uh
and in the first part of the lecture
we're going to bond the expectation of
this
as some kind of like weaker goal and in
the second part of the lecture if if we
have time we're going to bond it with
high probability without expectation in
front of it and once the expression
comes from this Randomness come from the
data
and the tuning data
right because L hat depends on the
training data and the genome data are
random ID drawn so that's why uh you uh
what things that the expectation is a
random variable that depends on the
randomness of the genome data and you
take expectations of this random
variable
uh and that's the that's the goal so
we're gonna Bond our upper bounders with
some other quantities that we think are
more intrinsic and convenient uh for us
to use
so
um
I guess I need to start with some
definitions
so
this this definition is called this is a
definition called rather marker
complexity
which is the main
object we're going to focus on in this
lecture so the definition is
let F be your family
of real
value functions
so far I have in this definition f is
just abstract family of functions and
we're going to define a complexity for
this family of functions F and then
we're going to say what functions of f
we are going to care about we care about
actually the functions of the losses the
the family of the losses but for now f
is just the abstract family of functions
and you're going to define a complex
measure for this abstract family
functions
so let's say this family functions that
Maps
some input space let's call it Z to real
number
um and
at p
be a distribution
over this input space z
then the average the so-called
often you don't really necessarily have
to specify as average when the marker
complexity but technically
is the average weather marker complexity
of f
is defined as
the following so this is r and sub f
where n indicates how many examples you
have how many chaining examples how many
empirical examples you have
R and F is defined to be
your first draw some examples
you can think of this as training
examples ID from the distribution p
and then you draw
some so-called rather Markov random
variables recall that by the market
random variables such as binary plus one
minus one uniform you you draw Sigma 1
up to Sigma n
i d
uniformly from -1 1.
and then you look at
this this
quantity you look at the soup
over this function class capital F and
you look at the quantity
the average of Sigma i f z i
and from 1 2. so this sounds like a kind
of like a pretty complicated
definition but let me try to interpret a
little
bit
um
so
in some sense maybe first of all only
think about this quantity right
just think about what's inside this soup
so this is the correlation
you know the one over n is is just a
normalization which is not important
this is the correlation
between
the outputs
of f right so the output of f is FZ1 up
to F zero right
and some random variable Sigma 1 and
sigma of course if you
uh just look at this right the
correlation should be in typically very
close to zero because you shouldn't
tolerate with random variables right but
there is a soup
right so you are first drawing the sigma
1 up to Sigma n and then you take a soup
over f so basically you are saying that
what's the maximal so basically this
whole thing
is the maximum correlation
between
F the output of F and sigma 1 up to
Sigma n after you draw Sigma X right so
you can you first just take my eye and
then you try to find something that
correlates with Sigma ice but you try to
find the app such that it can also put
something that looks like the random
things that you have to
you have done
so so in some sense if you have a high
complexity
means that
for most or for almost all for most of
binary patterns
where binary patterns just means that
you have the sigma 1 up to Sigma n there
exists f
in this hypo's class such that
the output on this family
is
similar to
or similar or correlated
with
a random pattern right so for any random
pattern if you draw it then you can find
post Hulk of a function f in this family
class such that the output on this
um on on 0 up to ZN looks like the
random pattern you have to run you have
to
so in some sense this is saying that how
diverse
the outputs you can have from this value
function itself right so if if this
family functions F can map your 0 up to
Z into any possible patterns then this
random Mark complexity will be the
largest right so for example suppose
every port
binary pattern can be somewhat output by
this family of functions F on Z then you
get the maximal uh random marker
complexity
intuitively
any questions so far
the question is is this necessarily a
non-increasing uh function of n
um
I think I should be but it shouldn't be
but I don't think it's trivial to see
why it's
Y is now increasing
um at least off the top of my head I
don't see a super simple argument
[Music]
um
but I think you can you can uh prove it
without too much effort I think roughly
speaking how do you prove it is that
you can because you take the soup right
so you somehow can
I think you can you can prove it by
switching the soup with expectation for
one
for example the last example and then
you got the roughly speaking the
definition of the N minus one uh version
of the value market complexity
um but maybe I may not do it on a fly
just in case I I missed some something I
got stuck so by the roughly speaking I
think that should work
any other questions
by the way I never got any questions
from Zoom so you should feel free to
speak up I I I just unmute yourself and
ask questions I sometimes I'm not even
sure whether the zoom is working
um
that's a great question so f is not uh
required to be mapped to plus one minus
one and it's true that this can be
unbounded right so this is actually
sensitive to the scale of f right if you
scale F by a factor of two then you're
gonna have uh uh two times the rather
Market complexity and this is actually
somewhat useful in certain cases
um which we probably will talk about
later
there is a question
okay
Okay cool so
um
so okay now let's see why we are care
about this so why we care about this
rather marker complexity
the reason is that
you know the following
so you know that
let me write down what
what is the theorem
supposed to do this hypothetic
experiment you draw
any examples from distribution p
and then you look at
this quantity
the average of f of z i i from 1 to n
minus the expectation of FZ right this
is kind of the quantity We have dealt
with uh in the last lecture the
concentration how much you deviate from
your
um from your mean but you take a seal
here because you carry it sometimes
carry about the maximum possible
deviation post talk after you draw the
examples
if you look at this quantity
then this quality is bonded by two times
the rather Markle complex co5
I guess to appreciate what the theorem
is really doing I guess it's probably
time to say what exactly what kind of if
we care about right so F so far is
abstract thing but now let's try to
instantiate
so it's supposed to take off
the capital F to be the family functions
that Maps Z
which is
taken to be a pair of X and Y the input
and output and we'll map it to the loss
function the loss of X Y on the
hypothesis h
for any age in the hypothesis so
basically this is the family of losses
for every model every model is a
function right and given that model and
you you get a a loss function
right defined by the Model H right so so
basically this is the composition of the
of the model function with the the the
the the the loss function
uh the two-dimensional loss function
right the little oil so together you
know basically you get the this is a map
from the data point to the loss of the
data point but you can vary uh what
functions uh what models you care about
so you get a family of losses
um so so in some sense it's just a
slightly it's a slight extension of the
family of models in some sense but but
here is it's about the losses and
suppose you care about this you take I
have to be this and you can see that the
left hand side is exactly what we are
worth trying to
um to bounce right just because you know
FDI
is laws of
x i I guess we write x i y I like this
x i y i
at h
right so then the sum of
the empirical sum is just the empirical
loss
right so whatever and sum of c f z i
this is just one over n times the sum of
L of x i y i
H this is just the loss the empirical
loss of the hypothesis class the
hypothesis h
right and the expectation of CI FZ
is the expectation of the loss
and where X and Y
are drawn from the distribution p and
this becomes the
population loss right so that's why the
left hand side of this theorem it's
really just the soup over h
L height h
minus LH
contact us
a quick question and you take
expectation over the randomness of the
data
so that's the that's the weaker version
of uniform convergence that we outline
in the beginning of the lecture
right so and you can bond this by the
random marker complexity of this
function cos F right the random marker
complexity of uh of this family of
losses
right so basically the theorem is saying
that
um the generalization error
is less than the rather Market
complexity of f
like I think technical expectation of
the generalization
um there was a question here
now there's no absolute value here yes
there's no absolute value that's a great
question so there's no apps value and it
becomes a little bit trickier if you
either absolute value I think if you add
absolute value
first of all you need a different proof
a slightly different proof and second
you're going to have a different
constant instead of two you can get
probably four
and and the cleanest way is to do it is
that you don't do absolute value
on in this theorem you do the absolute
value in the in the in the up in the in
the outer layer actually you don't even
need absolute value actually technically
because eventually you only cover one
side of the box when you do the
generalization so so technically we
don't even need absolute value anywhere
right
okay
so
and if you really think about this R and
F in this contact context right so so
for this particular F what does it mean
it really means that how well
the family of losses right so the losses
of data
and data
can correlate with random pattern
can correlate
so this still sounds a little bit kind
of like not super intuitive we can
further you know for simplified case we
can further uh simplify this a little
bit
so um so suppose you have a binary
classification
so suppose let's say your Y is between
plus one nine minus one
and L
is zero one loss
so L of x y h
is equals to the indicator
of H of X is not equals to Y if they are
done equal you have lost one otherwise
you have lost 0.
and in this case uh we can further
interpret this a little bit more so what
you can do is the following first of all
you will write this indicator into this
form
we write it as a half
times y minus 1 times h of x
um this is assuming
here I'm assuming h of X is also in plus
one minus one
so
um by the way and what I'm doing here is
to try to instantiate this into a
special case so that you can interpret
the rather marker complexity more
um in a more intuitive way
and also this this whole thing is also
useful by itself as well
um so
so when h of X is plus by minus one then
Y is plus one minus and also Y is plus
one minus one then the indicator that
they are different you can write this as
this because if Y and H are different
then you get yhx is -1 and then the
whole thing will be one and if Y and h x
are the same then y times HX is 1 and
then this quality this quantity is zero
so you can just verify it right so so
the reason we do this is we somehow make
it more linear in y and h x
and then you can look at the rather
marker complexity
so the R and F
is this expectation of soup
Sigma I
all right so and let's plug in the loss
so here are the expectation so some in
the definition I have two expectations
right so but now I put 12 expectations
into one that could be just you merge
them so that Randomness come from both
the data and the random marker patterns
and you get soup over h
so you plug in this formula a half times
one minus y i h x i
foreign
and now
let's do some real Arrangements
it's very simple rearrangement
Plus
one over n times a half
Sigma
so here
at this quantity
you know it's inside the soup right but
actually it's a constant that doesn't
depend on H
so you can pull it outside of the soup
so you can technically write this just
because this sum of Sigma I is a
constant
and then because now now you can switch
the expectation with the sum and get
expectation
soup of the first term
and plus the expectation of this one
over two and sum of Sigma I
and this term becomes zero
oh here
and this thing becomes zero because the
expectation of the radar micro variable
is zero
and so then we're only left with the
first quantity
and if you if you look at the first
quantity then you realize that
because so Sigma I is a random variable
right so H uh
why
why I Sigma I has the same distribution
Sigma I
right no matter what Y is right so for
even for y is one or four otherwise
minus one they have the exact same
distribution
so that's why you can replace why I say
actually you can also have minus here
that's still true
right because you only randomly flip the
Sun
right so so basically that means you can
replace y or Sigma minus y Sigma I by
Sigma itself I still you don't change
the expectation
right so you you can replace this by
maybe maybe let's define this you know I
guess you can say technical the easiest
way to check this I saw some confusion
easy ways to touch this you just Define
Sigma Prime to view minus y Sigma I then
you guys soup more and sum of h x i
Sigma Prime
but still take my subscribers
description is still plus one minus my
uniform and independent right so so
Sigma Prime has the same distribution as
Sigma I so you can just write this
the same way as
this
is
why
okay so so what we have achieved here
what we have achieved here is that this
seems to be a strictly simpler quality
than before why this is basically the
rather marker complexity
of the hypothesis class h
but now the family of losses
right before we are talking about the
hypothesis class of the family of losses
and now you are talking about the
exactly
write the marker complexity of the
hypothesis class h
so basically this is saying that
for bandwidth
I think I'm missing something I'm
missing a half here where where is the
half go
yeah I think I lost the half sorry
I think I lost oh I have the half in the
toes it's just I forgot to
copy it so
so basically this is a half times the
right on the complex so what we've
achieved is that the rather markup
complexity of f
in this special case of binary
classification and zero one loss is
equals to half times the rather Market
complexity of the hypothesis class
so
so that's a slightly simpler you know
way of thinking about this because
what's what's this this is basically
saying that
how while
H can memorize
memorize uh
the random random label
right you can think of Sigma 1 up to
Sigma n is random label and R and H is
Big when
you can there exists of H in the capital
h
such that
h of X I's
is equal to Sigma I this is the best
situation right this has the strongest
correlation so basically if you can
memorize all the random label with some
hypothesis in your hypothesis class that
means your random Mark complexity is the
biggest and that's gives you the worst
dramatization bound
um and the vice versa if you cannot
memorize then you get better
optimization
foreign
okay
I see okay that's a that's a good
question let me repeat the question so
the question is Sigma Prime is equals to
Y times actually there's a minus there
so but it doesn't matter so Sigma Prime
is minus y times Sigma I but y i itself
is random variable so can we still claim
that Sigma Prime has the same
distribution as Sigma
right so that's indeed that's a good
question so it's a so technically I
think what you should do is the
following
so if you are really careful about this
so there are two uh Randomness right so
one is from the X and one is from a
sigma so you first
condition on the randomness of oxide
to say that
so you first in the first expectation so
basically
how do I say this so you can write this
as the following right so
the condition on x i
y i
and then you look at the randomness of
Sigma I
right so now after you condition x i
then this is the absolutely clear right
so like for any choice of y i right
Sigma I and sigma Prime has the same
distribution condition any choice of
deterministic choice y
so then so so you do it inside and then
why
it's gone in your formula so then you
don't have to care about the the outside
cool
so it sounds good
and let me kind of like a so okay so the
take homework here is that you know the
random complex of f is similar to the
random complexity of the model and the
rather Mark complex of the model is
basically saying how well we can
memorize random label right but there is
a smoke caveat here which is that this
relationship is not always true
this relationship is true exactly true
for binary classification zero one loss
but it doesn't it's not even true for
for example some other loss function
so I think the intuitive largely is
still correct but
um but you cannot take this you know uh
literally or rigorously like religious
religiously for every situation and in
some cases it's actually there could be
a confusion because there could be cases
where
um these two are mismatched especially
if your loss function can do something
different for example your most function
could change the binary number to real
number or the Lost function uh has other
kind of properties right so for example
a loss function is also non-linear right
so suppose you take exponential loss so
and actually they are in some sense like
in the in the past they were this kind
of like um
in some extreme cases you could some
papers or some some papers actually
misinterpreted in some sense like
like a
um I I guess I'm just giving a warning
in some sense don't like always apply
this every time without even thinking
about it
um the intuition is roughly two but it's
not exactly sure
at all times you know I guess there will
be a place where I'm gonna mention this
again like in the later later of the
lecture
oh like in some of the later lectures
um
and
by the way just to and what we're going
to do next is I'm going to prove the
theorem
um and just a small kind of overview for
what we will do next lecture so so in
this lecture we are going to deal with
this abstract measure the rather Market
complexity right and you may wonder
probably some of you are wondering why
random art complexity is is something
measurable something like
um that is useful right so we don't
answer that today we're gonna answer
that you know in the next few lectures
so today we are just introducing this
rather more complex and say this is
bonding the uniform convergence and it's
rather more complexity something
intuitive I hope you found that right so
like if it's talking about how well you
can memorize labels right so if
something at least makes sense and in
the next few lectures we are going to
instantiate uh this to more concrete
models where you can Bond the radamer
complexly by something more concrete uh
in the next two lectures
I got some
oh
did somebody ask a question I didn't
hear
uh yeah I think a couple people chimed
in uh
you answered my question in the meantime
but someone else might have a question
still
yeah sorry I forgot to open my um I have
volume on if yeah please please ask
questions you know if you yeah now it's
working okay thank you
oh actually there is a question what is
the connection between the random or
complexity and the degree of freedom
right I think I assume by the degree of
freedom
um you mean the number of parameters
right so um so I guess that's kind of
like what we motivated in the beginning
so using this rather more complexity we
will be able to prove more precise
bounds
parameters so
um probably so far you haven't seen that
I I you know like I don't exactly to see
that but in the next lecture we're gonna
see you can prove better bonds that
depends on something more
um fungal than the number of parameters
I hope that answers questions please
feel free to just unmute yourself and
ask any follow-ups okay I guess
conceptual question how do you generally
think about the distinction between the
the hypothesis uh family of hypotheses
versus the family of losses over them uh
to me they because they have the same
cardinality right they seem like a
direct map in between one half like how
do you distinguish I guess in your mind
between those two how do you think about
them
yeah that's a that's a great question so
in my mind they are very similar except
that
um
except that I think this will be a
little more
um
explicit in the next lecture or maybe
two lectures later so except that when
you talk about the models the models
oftentimes ought to put a real number so
for example if you think about logistics
regression the model is output the
largest which could be anywhere on a
real line and they will turn that into a
probability and then use that
probability to compute a loss and the
loss becomes something first of all
non-native and often sometimes the loss
is you know reasonably it's between zero
and one but logistic loss it's not
between a zero and one but I think the
most interesting regime is that it's
somewhat small right so it's between
zero and one and and if you care about
classification loss then there's
literally between zero and what so so
the loss function sometimes has uh has a
scale in some sense like it's it's
something on out of one and but your
model could be uh Sometimes outputting
some bigger numbers
um
so so there is a conversion there which
will be more explicit in the future
lectures but besides beyond that
um I don't typically I don't distinguish
them uh very much
yeah I thought it interesting that in
your in the example at least for binary
classification the the complexity of the
uh the loss family was less than half of
the complexity of the model family is
that is it common that the your
complexity goes down when you compose it
with a loss function
um I think it's common that they are
related we will see that in many cases
they can be related but I think I
wouldn't read too much from that
constant half because it's a half does
depend on how you
Define your own labels for example if
your label is 0 1 I think you wouldn't
see the half
so there is some small artifact area
right so the constant so it doesn't
really matter
okay cool okay let's continue so
um so we're gonna prove this and this is
called symmetrization technique the
proof and this is a very um
this is a technique that can be used in
many other cases
not necessarily in this course but in
other kind of like
areas of probability let's say
um
so symmetricization technique I think it
probably comes from those kind of
average probability
um anyways in the first place so
um
so the technique is that
um let's write down what we care about
so
because what we care about is the soup
let me not take a spectation for now
just so that it's a little bit cleaner
we will take expectation
in a bit
so this is not symmetric in some sense
because you have
um
you have this you know subtraction here
and
so so these two terms don't look the
same but that's that's what I mean by
not smash Loop so there's a way to make
them some somehow more symmetric so what
you do is you is that
if you fix for now let's say we fixed
X1 Z1 after Z1
and we let Z1 Prime and z n Prime to be
a different drawing another draw
from
the distribution p and ID so you draw a
sequence of copies of Zima of position
ID
and then what you can do is that you can
say
can write this
second
the expectation this quantity
using the zi Prime
you know just uh because by definition
you know all the zis have the same
uh distribution from P so expectation of
f is really the same as you look at
expectation of sum of f of z i Prime
because each of this term has
expectation the same as your EF and and
you average them so you get eo5
right so and you see that you know this
already makes it a little bit more
symmetric uh for whatever you know like
just looks on the surface looks more
symmetric because this is the sum of
things and this is some of things of
course it's still a little bit different
because the expectation
uh is in front of this thing but there's
no expectation in front of the first so
um what we can do is you can uh of
course one thing you can do is you can
put the expectation in front of the both
term
which is not doing really anything
because
for now zi is constant and z a prime Is
Random
so in some sense you are just putting
some constant inside expectation
and now let's what happens is that you
can switch the expectation with the soup
maybe let's ask the question first
oh sorry yeah sorry
it's this one yeah cool thanks yeah so
now uh we'll make it more symmetric so
we'll switch
uh the expectation with the soup so I'm
claiming that if you switch them you get
an inequality
the prime
right so why this is true and this is
just a this is just a very generic
inequality where which claims that you
can
replace switch to an expectation get
inequality so generically this is the
claim is that suppose you have a
function G that takes in two variables
and suppose you are taking expectation
first
over the randomness of the first bar the
second variable and then you take Soup
over the first bar the and you take Soup
over the first variable suppose this is
the quantity you have then you can
replace this by
eventually by first taking expectation
and then actually by first taking a soup
and then taking expectation
but because when you do the math you are
doing it from right hand side to the
left hand side
and why this is true this is because
you can have an intermediate step which
is you take Soup
over you
take expectation over B and you bound
this g u v by Silk
over u g u
maybe that's called U Prime
right so this inequality is very simple
it's just because this term is unsure
what term wise bonded by the soup
and and once you do the steel then you
see that
this whole thing doesn't depend on you
anymore right so maybe I should have
another step so
actually I'm claiming that this is just
equal to this
because this term
doesn't depend on you you already got
rid of you
right so so the soup over you
just can be gone and then the green term
is equals to the term below just because
you change the variable name U to U
Prime that's not nothing
right so that's why it's equality
so in general it's kind of like just
probably useful to kind of know this as
a fact so you can switch the soup with
expectation and get inequality
um
sometimes I do I don't remember which in
which direction thing of course it is so
that's why you still want to probably
somewhat know how to prove it so that in
case you got confused which direction it
is you you can still recover it
um Okay cool so
um okay so that's the that's how this
works
and now if you take expectation over Z
again we already condition on Z but not
suppose let's take expectation over Z
then you see that this is kind of like
very symmetric so what we got is that
its expectation over Z1 up to z n
that's bonded by now you have two
expectations here one is over Z times
and the other is of over z i Primes
and then you have soup
let's put it into a single sum by the
way
okay
so now it becomes a little more
symmetric and I'll do some one more
thing to make it even more symmetric
so
um
this one
it's magic in the sense that actually is
a mean zero random variable
right it's not going to even mean zero
but actually in terms of distribution is
is the discussion is Magic in the
following sense so FCI
minus FCI Prime
has the same distribution
as fzf1 minus FCI
because these two things are just the
renaming of each other in some sense so
they have the same distribution or in
other words this has the same
distribution as Sigma I
FCI
minus FCI Prime
for any Sigma for any Sigma I
that is binary
right if it's minus one if it's plus one
is the same thing it's responded spine
just to flip the order and
so so that means that you can
for free introduce this random variable
Sigma I and and not not change anything
so that means that if you introduce this
rather Markov random variable
and you take expectation over Sigma ions
you multiply the sigma I
this fcm as FDR Prime
so this is still in equality
actually like here even you choose any
Sigma I this is equality of course if
you choose random Sigma is you know on
average them is still equality
okay
so I think technically you you for like
you claim that for any Sigma idccality
technically the first step is this is
equality for every Sigma I for any Sigma
I
and then you say that even you take
another expectation over Sigma ice
that's still true
it's still true and then you can switch
the expectation whatever you want
okay and I'm going to switch it just
because it's a little bit convenient for
me too
do that
okay
so
so now what I'm going to do is that I'm
going to
uh
work this to work this into two sums
so I'm going to have expectations here
you have all the randomness
is this just a simplification of
rotation so I'm claiming that this is
less than soup of
the first term
plus the soup
of the second term
and here what we are doing is
essentially exactly the same thing as
the the switch of the expectation the
spec of the expectation and and the soup
but here we only have two terms so it's
a swipe of sum and soup so here we are
we are doing something like soup of two
terms so something like a function of F
plus another function five
over F and then you can say that this is
less than
soup of f u of f
2
05.
I guess you can prove this you know
almost the same way as we have done with
the expectation as well it's just you
need one step in the middle uh I will
leave faces as a exercise for you so
and now
probably have seen that we are getting
closer and closer to the definition of
Nevada Market complexity the only thing
is that we have two terms and the right
Market complexity have just the only of
this so now we can change this to
the we can swap the expectation with the
sum so you got soup
CI
and here and plus
expectation soup
minus sign FCI Prime
and here the randomness is
Z1 up to z n and sigma 1 up to Sigma so
this is exactly the first term is
exactly By the Mark complexity and I'm
going to claim that the second term is
also exactly random or complexity
because
here
the my Randomness is E1 C1 Prime up to Z
and Prime and sigma 1 up to Sigma n
but again because minus Sigma i f z i
Prime has the same distribution
as Sigma i f z i
right because minus Sigma has the same
distribution Sigma I and z i Prime has
the same distribution z i
so then the second term is still
this is equals to the first term
so basically this is just equals to two
times
this
is 2 times the random number five
the questions
that's the quick question and that's
exactly what I'm going to remark on so
the question was
um you know if I freeze it slightly
differently so what we have really done
here did we do anything that's kind of
like powerful or did we do something
because the left hand side it has a soup
the right hand side still has a soup
right so uh did we do something really
useful or did we just do a bunch of
algebra right so I'm gonna claim that we
did do something useful and the reason
is that
um the left hand side you know it's
something like a soup
is what we care about right the the
difference between empirical mean and
the
and uh and the the the population mean
right
so on the right hand side
roughly speaking the the most important
thing is this this thing
so what we have achieved here
so
so one we have achieved that
we remove
the
yeah
right so we've got we'll get rid of the
EF
and
it's probably you know not super clear
why we should appreciate this fact that
we got rid of the EF and the first set
but I can say that this EF is you know
it's somewhat kind of annoying because
you don't have a good control on it
right so when you look at this in some
sense this quantity doesn't depend on
the relative
uh like for example this point it does
depend on if EF right so if you shift it
a little bit it wouldn't change actually
we're going to claim that this coin to
the right hand side is translation
environment so so in some sense you move
the remove the the translation
environment part
so maybe let me just claim
the the right hand side is translation
environment
or maybe the mock the rather marker
complexity
I'm going to claim that prove this in
your moment
let me see what I plan to do this in
today's lecture
I think I didn't plan to do it today's
lecture but but this is a crime so in
some sense you remove the the
translation environment part you remove
the EF right so which is useful in many
cases and
second
you sometimes introduce more randomness
Sigma 1 up to Sigma n
so while introducing this Randomness is
useful
it's probably still unclear
right now but eventually what we're
going to do is that we are going to have
So So currently what we really have is
you have expectation of this right you
also haven't expected of this and here
the randomness is Z1 up to ZN and sigma
1 up to Sigma
right so we will use additional
Randomness and this allows us this will
allows us
to drop
a randomness
from Z1 up to zero
um this will this will be something
we'll see I guess probably
in the next lecture
So So eventually you don't have to care
about the the you don't have to take
expectation over Z1 plus year you can
you can claim with high probability uh
uh so the red price I wouldn't have to
run like Z1 after CM you don't need to
take expectation over Z by up to Z and
the only Randomness come from the sigma
ice which
uh if you eventually I guess probably
you you don't see exactly what I mean
but if eventually you only care about
the randomness of Sigma to Sigma I a
sigma 1 up to Sigma and that's that's uh
that seems to be a a benefit because
this is a very simple much simpler
randomness right so Sigma up to Sigma
has a very simple distribution if they
are just random markers random variables
so they are much less complicated than
the distribution of c bar to Z which is
something you don't know right you just
assume there's a distribution P but you
didn't really know any other properties
about it
so so I think that's the
um that's the second benefit
um but of course the limitation is that
we still have the soup which is still a
problem but I think you probably
wouldn't shouldn't expect that you can
remove the soup on this level when you
have abstract family class
um you'll probably shouldn't expect you
can remove the soup completely right so
it should be the next level where you
remove the soup when you have a concrete
hypothesis
um
cool
so the next part is another
um
useful
property or kind of useful thing to know
about rather Mark complexity which is
that it's rather more complexity can
depend
on the distribution p
it still can depend on the solution p
even though you know our goal is to try
to kind of like use the new Randomness
right the deal with the simpler
randomness
right why this is the case
um this is just because
in this definition of random marker
complexity you do have to draw some
z-ramp to Zero from the distribution p
right so this is a gym example where you
can see that
um
um where p is a point nice
so let's say Z is always equal to Z zero
almost right so whatever how you draw it
you always just draw a single point
and in this case actually you can have a
good runner marker complexity
for any bounded function so suppose
let's say minus one
suppose you care about
you know
and this is the only constraint on the
Family app so basically you care about F
or maybe more tech let's say f is the
family of functions F such that
fz0
expounded by one so we just have a
boundary family of functions you don't
even have any parametric form
still you can prove that the right
number complex of this family of on this
family is small
so you can say that
if you look at soup
so this is what
because FDI is always the same so this
is it it literally equals to one of n
times F zero
times sum of Sigma I
and because you know fz0 is just a
constant it doesn't depend on what f is
right because Z zero is wait sorry my
bad so F I'm wrong with that let's see
so
box fz0 it still depends on Z zero right
but fc0 is bounded between 0 and 1.
between -1 so that that means that this
is less than or equal to expectation if
you just bound this f z 0 by 1 you get
one over n times sum of Sigma i absolute
value
right so and
this is actually
um
then use caution Source or use the
uh I think this is called cautious words
so the expectation of this random
variable is smaller than the
expectation of the square of the random
variable
to the power of half
and then you can
after these derivations we're going to
see this configuration several times so
you get
uh
a half expectation
sum of Sigma I Sigma J
is not equals to J this plus sum of
Sigma I Square
times y Over N Square
right I'm just expanding uh expanding
rate so you get one over n Square
Sigma Sigma J has mean zero so you get
sum over I from 1 to n expectation Sigma
I Square
a half so this is
each of this is one you take the sum we
get n so you get one over n to the power
of half is power squared
so
so in some sense this is kind of like
interesting right so like for very very
large family functions without even
parametric form you can still have a
good random complexity and the reason is
that the distribution is so simple
so it's in some sense this is indeed
this is the indicator that you the
radamer complexity can capture something
about the distribution right if the
distribution is driven it's simple then
rather marker complex they can capture
that and tell you that
um your uh it's very easy to generalize
right right so so basically
only have on a very simple distribution
should be considered by considered as
very simple even though this
and sometimes this family of f is just
you have basically no assumptions in
some sense right there is no parametric
form is it's a very large family of
functions but with respect to the
distribution the simple distribution it
should be considered as simple and this
is what weather marker complexity can
tell you so that's saying that's rather
more complex it can take into account uh
the discussion p
um
but how much it can take into account of
the diffusion P that's the question
marks right so in many of the other
analysis you
don't like in manual analysis you don't
have this property like you don't really
use too much about the solution p in
many of the concrete bounds for random
or complexity but in principle it can
capture something about p
uh
I have 15 minutes I think there is time
for me to do this next part
let's see
here I think I have time to do this
okay
so the next part if there's any no
questions
but I mean it is it possible
so so your question is whether for
example when the features X the
coordinates of X have correlations
or maybe you have Independence
Independence is uh probably it's more
like a simplistic thing right so can you
get a better bond from random marker
complexity
um
I think this to answer this question we
need to zoom in to
um concrete settings
right for linear models I guess
you see that you would get bonds at
least you know if you compare two
extreme cases where in one case all the
coordinates are correlated
and the other case is that
actually it's unclear right so because
if all the coins are correlated actually
you probably should have a better Bond
because if for example in a very very
extreme case right so all the
coordinates are the same
then you effectively have a
one-dimensional problem so you should
have a better Bond
so so it does depend on the particular
situation I think
right so so yeah so it's interesting
right it's not clear that Independence
means really simpler
Independence could mean that it's com
more complicated
just because we have independent input
distribution right so you have a diverse
set of distribution that first set of
data
it might be even more it's harder to
generalize in some cases right so for
example here in this one point much case
right you have a very nice family of
data it means if you can generalize
easier because you can memorize that
zero
right so so Independence might make it
harder
okay so the next 15 to 10 to 15 minutes
let me try to uh Define the so-called
empirical random marker complexity
and the goal here is to remove that
expectation in front of the
in front of the soup right so so
currently the average version has two
expectations one is
over the randomness of 0 up to ZN and
there's another expectation of the
randomness that we created
right over Sigma 1 up to Sigma and you
have this soup
and we're going to claim that this is
basically similar to
this
without expectation
with high probability
so with high probability
and the probability is over the runness
of Z1 to zero right so you still you
have to draw Z by up to z n but for most
of the choice of Z1 up to z n
these two things are similar
right so this is the random variable
that depends on Z1 of position this is
the random this is just a constant right
this this number is a it's not a random
number it's a
yeah I probably shouldn't call it
constant this is a deterministic number
right so this number depends on zero up
to z n and I'm claiming that
the second one the right hand side is
concentrating around the first one
um
with high probability
so and if you can do this then that's
what we I kind of alluded to before
right so now if this is defined to be
empirical rather micro complexity
um I guess so let me have a notation for
that
foreign
I think let me just uh
I think you'll notice there is a formal
definition but here let me just for the
sake of time let's just Define this to
be r s of f
where s is
the set of 0 up to zero
and this is called empirical rather
marker complexity
and and you can see that the original
red marker complexity the average one of
our complexity is the expectation of the
empirical value Mark complexity
where you take expectation over the set
s
right
so just because these two things only
differ by a single expectation
and so if you can do this then
you have a
uh you have a high probability Bond you
don't have to average over zero up to
seven and also you can do the same thing
for the left hand side for the uniform
convergence thing right so recall that
before we only prove that
the expectation of the above to zione
soup
this minus EF right we want to prove
that this is less than random micro
complexity
right so this one
we will also show that this is
approximately
equals to this with high probability
like I guess I should say
the later one
this one later one is a random variable
right that depends on z bar to z n is
approximately equal to the expectation
with high probability
so if you have both of this then you
basically remove the expectation from
your equation and you get a high
probability
does that make sense
any questions
so basically eventually we're going to
prove this so let me say the formal
serum
we can prove that
you see all the effects are bounded
then
with probability at least
one minus Delta
we have the soup
so here I don't have expectation this is
the
but there's a run over the randomness
Z1 up to z n
soup
this
is less than
two
times
the internal correct number complexity
is after
I will draw the mark complexity plus
additional cost
additional term which is the log long
of 2 over Delta
over 2 and so you pay additional small
term which is on the auto four over
square root and times some log something
logarithmic
in a probability Delta
um
so and but basically by paying this you
get a high probability Bond instead of
the average person
I think the proof here the proof is
actually relatively
straightforward it's basically just
applying
uh mcdermen inequality
um but maybe let me do that in the next
lecture I think it takes probably 10
minutes
[Music]
maybe let me start with the remark right
so
so I guess typically this
loan to Delta over n
this is typically much smaller than
either the rather marker complexity
or the the either the empirical one or
the population one
and
the reason is that these two things will
be something like square root something
over n and if something depends on
the complexity of f it's something that
is not negligible but here you have
square root a logarithmic some
logarithmic term over n so that's pretty
much the smallest thing you can think of
right so like a algorithmic is kind of
like a constant
so so your complexity of f wouldn't be a
on a logarithmic uh of anything it
should be something bigger than that so
that's why typically this additional
term
um is negligible so that's why basically
you can think of this
um you didn't lose anything by doing the
empirical version
and it's interesting that what you lose
here at this on this level
what you lose here doesn't depend on
complex of f
right so basically if you
um so so this term depends on complex
five but what you lose here between the
expected empirical and population don't
depend on complex
foreign
and maybe I think this is a perfect time
for doing a second remark
two
so and I guess R and F
or risf
they are both translation environment
so uh what does that mean that means
that suppose
you have F Prime which is equals to
a translation of f which means that this
is a family of function
F Prime Z which is equals to f z plus u
a universal constant C zero
right so for every function in capital F
you've got the function capital F Prime
which is just a translation uh you just
add some c0 to it
then
they have the same
empirical by the marker complexity
and in some sense we have seen this
derivation somewhere in the in this um
in one of the irrigations before but let
me just to make it more explicit
so
the the rather more complex of this is
you look at the expectation of Sigma
and you take the soup off
sum of Sigma i f I Prime
F Prime
CI
and
you plug in a definition
plus zero
but
right so now you can
put the part about c0 I think we have
seen the same technique before because
c0 is not a function of little f so you
can put it out so you get
Plus
one over n times sum of Sigma I times c0
and then you can survive expectations
with the sum so you get expectation
signal
the soup
plus expectation of y Over N times sum
of Sigma i c 0.
and this becomes zero because Sigma I is
a binary uh or it's a red marker random
variable so then this is RS of f
so
so in some sense this is a property of
the radical complexity which is um
like a
somewhat interesting right like you
don't care about the translation but you
do care about a scale so if you scale
everything by half or by two then you
would change the value of complexity but
I wouldn't change when you shift things
so it's about the relative differences
between functions here it's not not
about the absolute
size or five right so so for example if
the function of F always takes values
between one thousand and one thousand
one that's not very different from
taking values between zero and one
okay I think this is an actual stopping
point uh for today
um any questions
uh first of all it's not always the case
that
right that's a good question right so I
I claim this you know regularly without
any justification so why the rather
Market complexity should be like this by
one of our scripted so I think it's not
even
so I should say it's not actually
exactly true like so for most of the
case actually for all the cases we are
going to see in this
in the lectures it's one over square
rooted but in some cases it could be the
dependency on could be a little bit
different
um so yeah so sorry I was not quite
clear and I think I'm not sure whether
that's questions still in the homework I
think in the homework question there
used to be a question
um where you have other dependencies on
I think I probably removed that question
for this year
um I remember I remove it just because
it's not that relevant to the overall
goal but but there could be other
dependencies
um for some reason it's always like
it's mostly the case is one of the
scrotum I think this the reason is that
the even you look at a single
uh even you look at a single
example you don't take the soup
right you just look at the like a like
you you do the wrong thing right so you
you say I fixed my function and then I
draw my data I look at how different the
empirical one is different from the
population one right that's always one
over square rooted like without any
doubt right so so that's why you can
never go better than lava Square rooting
but you can be worse than lava script
I'm not sure why that makes sense right
so if you look at a single
the concentration of a single at a
single F right like you fix the the
function H you draw the random variable
Z1 up to Z and you still have some
fluctuation on order for our Square
rooting so you cannot repeat that
but it could be worse than that
from definition of the random marker I
think you can still see that to some
extent because if you look at the sum of
Sigma I i5
maybe let's just a here right so this is
still a sum of N terms
right and and each of so like if you
don't take the soup this term would be
something on all of our square rooted
that's because of the Constitution right
you have sum of N terms each of them is
on the other one so the sum of the
instruments is on all the square root
and and then you divide by n you get one
over square root
we can talk more offline Maybe
okay sounds good I guess I'll see you on
Monday or Wednesday